here now is house minority leader kevin
mccarthy a little shad and freud here
congressman the table can be turned
really quickly can it when race
is a card that you drop just to avoid an
argument
that's what they try this is internal
war this this isn't a family feud this
is beyond what anyone thinks
when you see also you didn't put up what
aoc's chief of staff said yes have it
have it challenged any voter to tell us
what the democrats have accomplished for
america's kitchen table
and then question this legislative
mastermind referring to nancy pelosi
yeah well
is this just a you know a passing
rift here this is all healed up because
what are they doing now
they're challenging these democrats in
primaries the social
the socialist democrats are taking over
not only have they taken over the party
they're gonna
they're gonna take on any democrat in
that process as well so they're not
doing any legislative business
and it's affecting what they do on the
floor we've got the national defense
authorization bill up
for 60 years it's been bipartisan it
passed the senate with 86 votes
no they've made it completely partisan
instead of putting the troops first
they've gone to politics
because of this the socialism aoc as i
said in my angle criticizes anyone in
any one and
everywhere anytime she wants and she has
social media okay
that's fine but you're in you're in the
big dog's pen now
okay big dogs bite like you you bite it
a bit if it's like the old you're gonna
kill the king kill the king yeah pretend
you're gonna get it go for
but so i can't get it if are you strong
young
girl power or is it okay i get hit and
it's the damsel in distress thing i
don't understand that it's like hit
woman here might
hear me roar and then it's oh no don't
it i don't like that no she's one thing
she wants to be cool in some ways but
that
that's that's just not that doesn't work
but think for one moment
a year ago this month you had never
heard of her until she beat crowley in a
primary
she's moved very fast but she always
wants to try to use advantage she'll
fight
until you fight back then she wants to
play a race card or something but then
it's
you can't ever criticize a person of
color but then we have people of color
democrats are saying whoa whoa whoa
now let's talk about what's happening
this weekend the administration
and i talked about this with john you a
few moments ago has
announced that they're doing ten major
city raids
um and it was delayed earlier after an
outrage and i don't really know why it
was delayed but
here's senator maisie hirono saying
about
who's being targeted let's watch a lot
of these people
do have supposedly deportation orders
but
you know we also know of cases of people
who had deportation orders
and who were appealing their deportation
orders
um i don't know if that's like a
hawaiian way of saying that's not true
but uh that's not even true even the new
york times agrees
yes but that's not the worst thing we
heard today about the raids
fairly reminiscent of nazi germany just
saying i know you're not supposed to
make that connection
but i've been around long enough and
i've read enough to know that this is
very similar to what happened to the
jews
leader mccarthy how do we ever have a
sensible immigration policy this is the
kind of language so
in other words no deportation you can't
detain people
and you can't deport people and you
can't criminalize border crossings
what else america's one of the greatest
strengths is the rule of law
these individuals have their day in
court
legally it tells them they have to leave
it's not like someone's just going to go
pick them up
they had their day the court has ordered
them to leave they will not leave
and we're going to say that's not right
they're going to pick them up they're
going to deport them just as the
just as uh the law says they should just
as bill clinton said we had to do just
as dianne feinstein said
i love all the old clips harry reid uh
barbara jordan like this
they said in the state of the union how
many people did
president obama deport 20 20 dems
tonight on the
uh raids let's watch this is
all kinds of wrong and we're a better
country than this to be separating
families that's really
of course not about making america safer
but about
striking fear into as many people as
possible in order to keep this crisis
in the headlines a crime against
humanity
crime against uh logical thought but she
was a prosecutor too
she has a law degree doesn't she believe
in the rule of law
if she if she broke the law would she
uphold in the place
here who else can avoid court orders
yeah
they want to allow everybody just to
come in the country whether it's illegal
or not
what are we doing with 130 000 homeless
in california
how many of those are veterans but now
we're going to encourage people to come
here illegally
provide them health care but not take
care of the americans that are here
it's absurd what they believe well
they've come a long way baby haven't
they
okay but we got it we can't allow it to
go on social media summit was it
was it it was good look you should be
very concerned what about your privacy
and one
that these countries have these
companies have so much control ninety
percent of every search goes through
google
what they know about you what they can
say about you and what they can
determine and
affect what you understand uh by the way
real election meddling could be coming
not from russia real election meddling
from big media and i'm glad
this is being examined by the
administration a lot more needs to be
done by the justice department thank you
so much